>> Laura: GOOD EVENING FROM
WASHINGTON, I'M LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS A "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
A ROLLICKING INTERVIEW BETWEEN
HANNITY AND RUDY GIULIANI JUST
CONCLUDING.
THE FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
AND NEWLY APPOINTED TRUMP
ATTORNEY DISHING ON THE TRUMP
LEGAL STRATEGY, JIM COMEY, BOB
MUELLER, AND WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT WILL SUBMIT TO A
SPECIAL COUNSEL INTERVIEW, EVEN
REVEALING A NEW DETAIL THAT HAS
THE LEFT GOING NUTS TONIGHT
ABOUT THE ALLEGED STORMY DANIELS
PAYOUT.
WE ARE GOING TO BREAK IT ALL
DOWN FOR YOU TONIGHT, THE SLOT
TO GET TO SO LET'S FIRST HEAR
RUDY ON WHY POTENTIAL TRUMP
INTERVIEW WITH MUELLER'S TEAM
STANDS.
>> IT FALLS MORE ON US BECAUSE
IT'S ON THE GOVERNMENT SIDE
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
GRANT AN INTERVIEW.
IT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT -- IT'S
REALLY SIMPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN FOLLOW
THIS ALONG WITH ME.
ARE THE OBJECTIVE?
ARE THEY?
RIGHT NOW, A LOT OF THINGS POINT
IN THE DIRECTION OF THEY MADE UP
THEIR MIND THAT COMEY IS TELLING
THE TRUTH AND NOT THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE QUESTIONS
BUT WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT
THINK, WHAT DOES HE FEEL, WHAT
IS HE REALLY DESIRE, THOSE ARE
ALL QUESTIONS INTENDED TO TRAP
HIM.
>> Laura: LET'S BRING IN BYRON
WORK IN WASHINGTON.
AND IN ARIZONA, CONGRESSMAN ANDY
BIGS A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
FREEDOM CAUCUS AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, WE HAVE A LOT TO GET
THROUGH TONIGHT.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU FIRST.
I HOPE YOU WERE ABLE TO WATCH
THAT INTERVIEW WITH RUDY.
WHAT STRUCK YOU ABOUT WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT COMEY, MUELLER, AND
THE ENTIRE YEAR OF INVESTIGATION
MANIA.
>> MY IMPRESSION IS THAT HE'S
GOT IT RIGHT IN MY FRUSTRATION
IS THAT WE GONE A YEAR AND THERE
IS NO CRIMINAL ACTIVITY, AND
THIS IS JUST -- THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS NOT OBJECTIVE
AND THAT REALLY RESONATES
BECAUSE IT'S NOT OBJECTIVE.
IT'S BIASED AND THEY ARE TRYING
TO USE THESE QUESTIONS, IT'S
GOING TO BE A TRAP FEST FOR
MUELLER AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THEY JUST WANT TO GO AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: THERE'S SO MUCH TO
UNPACK.
THIS IS WHAT RUDY SAID ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE INVESTIGATION AND
WHETHER IT SHOULD WRAP UP, LET'S
WATCH.
>> I BELIEVE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SESSIONS, MY GOOD FRIEND AND
ROSENSTEIN -- WHO I DON'T KNOW,
I BELIEVE IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE THEY SHOULD END THE
INVESTIGATION.
THERE HAS BEEN TOO MUCH
GOVERNMENT MISCONDUCT.
THE CRIMES HAVE ALL BEEN
COMMITTED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
>> Laura: WOW.
THAT WAS A MOMENT, THE CRIMES
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN I WATCHED, WHY WOULD HE
HAVE MADE AN INTERESTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL PICK.
>> I THINK WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS SINCE THE RELEASE
OF THESE QUESTIONS FROM MUELLER
AND NOW THIS WITH INTERVIEW ON
HANNITY, I THINK WE'VE SEEN A
DRAMATIC CHANGE IN THIS CASE.
THE LAWYERS, JOHN DOWD AND TY
COBB WHO WERE COUNSELING A MORE
CONCILIATORY APPROACH TOWARD
MUELLER, THEY ARE GONE.
WE HAD THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER GO
ON TV FOR AN HOUR.
HE DIDN'T SEE DOWD OR COBB DOING
THAT.
IF THE ONE THING THAT RUDY SAYS,
HE THINKS THE ODDS ARE AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP SITTING DOWN AND
TALKING WITH MUELLER.
THEY MADE A LOT OF NEWS IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS.
>> Laura: HERE'S THE DEAL.
WE HAVE HAD A STRING OF
ATTORNEYS FOR THE PRESIDENT, TY
COBB IS LEAVING AT THE END OF
MAY.
JOHN DOWD EXITED IN MARCH.
THERE STILL IS MARTY AND JANE
RASKIN RECENTLY BROUGHT ON THE
TEAM.
CASTLE WITS, HIS PERSONAL
ATTORNEY, ONE OF HIS PERSONAL
ATTORNEYS, HE WAS IN AND OUT
BRIEFLY.
NOW THEY BRING IN EMMETT FLOOD.
IN FULL DISCLOSURE, WE WERE
COCLERKS BACK IN THE DAY, YOU
SEE HIM ON THE UPPER LEFT-HAND
CORNER.
FLOOD IS THE KIND OF ATTORNEY
WHO IS NOT GOING TO GIVE A LOT
OF INTERVIEWS ON TELEVISION,
HE'S ONE OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
I KNOW.
ONE OF THE FINEST PEOPLE I KNOW.
JUST TOP-NOTCH, THE KIND OF
PERSON THAT SHOULD'VE BEEN IN
FRONT AND RIGHT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
HE WORKED FOR CLINTON DURING THE
IMPEACHMENT INVESTIGATION, HE'S
AT WILLIAMS AND CONNELLY.
THIS DOES TELL YOU THAT THE
TRUMP TEAM HAS GOTTEN SERIOUS.
HE'S GOING TO GO FOR THE BIG
GET.
>> IT WASN'T JUST CLINTON, HE
ALSO REPRESENTED DICK CHENEY IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND HE ALSO
REPRESENTED THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL OFFICE UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL.
HE'S GOT EXPERIENCE IN BOTH
TIMES OF ADMINISTRATION.
SPEAKING TO SOMEBODY WITH
IMPEACHMENT EXPERIENCE, THE
SCALES HAVE FALLEN AND THEY
REALIZE THE STAKES ARE ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT HERE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE QUESTIONS IN
THE MUELLER LEAKS.
THEY ARE NOT ABOUT ANY CRIME THE
PRESIDENT MAY HAVE COMMITTED,
IT'S CLEARLY DOING SOME FREE
RESEARCH FOR THE DEMOCRATS, IT
COULD NOT BE CLEARER.
I'M GLAD AS A SUPPORTER OF THE
PRESIDENT, TO SEE THEY FINALLY
WOKE UP.
THE RUDY GIULIANI INTERVIEW, IT
WAS VERY ENCOURAGING TO ME, TO
SEE SOMEBODY WITH REALITY CHECKS
HERE.
WE'VE SEEN THE CONDUCT THAT HAS
BEEN COMMITTED AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT SO FAR.
I FEEL MUCH MORE REASSURED TO
SEEING THEM GIRDING FOR BATTLE
HERE.
>> Laura: THE BIG NEWS
YESTERDAY WITH THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS, I FOCUS ON ROB
ROSENSTEIN, IT WAS KIND OF A
BRUSHOFF OF ROSENSTEIN JUST
THERE.
THERE PICKING IT UP, YOU GUYS
SEEM TO BE PICKING IT UP IN THE
HOUSE AND RUDY HIMSELF SAID THIS
ABOUT COMEY, DEVASTATING.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I KNOW JAMES COMEY, I KNOW
THE PRESIDENT.
SORRY JIM, YOU'RE A LIAR.
A DISGRACEFUL LIAR.
EVERY FBI AGENT IN AMERICA HAS
HIS HEAD DOWN BECAUSE OF YOU.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN GOOD FOR GOD IF
GOD WOULD'VE KEPT YOU OUT OF
BEING HEAD OF THE FBI.
>> AMEN TO THAT, THAT'S ONE OF
THE COMMENTS WHEN HE SAYS THAT I
STAND UP AND CHEER.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THAT, WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO MAKE IT CLEAR.
THANK GOODNESS FOR RUDY GIULIANI
SAYING THAT.
MR. COMEY HAS BEEN A DISGRACE.
TREY GOWDY SAID GREAT.
NOBODY HAS BROUGHT MORE
DISREPUTE ON THE FBI THAN JAMES
COMEY.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE AS A
NATION, I CAN'T GO TO
CONSTITUENTS -- THEY ARE ALL
UPSET, WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
COMEY, WHY ISN'T HE BEHIND BARS,
HE NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED
HIMSELF.
>> Laura: WE HAVE THIS MOMENT
ABOUT EXTORTION.
WHEN ROD ROSENSTEIN YESTERDAY
SAID WE AREN'T GOING TO BE
EXTORTED AS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND BACKING DOWN AND
BEING INTIMIDATED -- A NUMBER OF
EDITORIALS WRITTEN AND COLUMNS
WRITTEN, THERE WAS ONE ON USA
TODAY BY TWO PROMINENT
DEMOCRATS, A FORMER OBAMA
OFFICIAL AND FRED WERTHEIMER AT
THE BROOKINGS INSTITUTION SAYING
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS AND THE
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING THE
BIDDING OF THE PRESIDENT, TRYING
TO INTIMIDATE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE -- IT'S A
DISGRACE.
IF IT WAS HOT BEFORE, IT'S BEING
RAMPED UP NOW ON BOTH SIDES.
>> DOES ART GO TO WAR WORDS, THE
EXTORTION THING.
PEOPLE IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WHO ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO FEEL
THEY'VE GIVEN TOO MUCH TO
CONGRESS.
I CANNOT SAY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD HAND OVER
EVERY SINGLE DOCUMENT TO
CONGRESS.
ROSENSTEIN WOULD HAVE MORE
CREDIBILITY TODAY IF HE HAD NOT
MADE GETTING DOCUMENTS LIKE
PULLING TEETH FOR CONGRESS OVER
THE LAST YEAR.
PAUL RYAN IS NOT A BIG WARRIOR
IN THIS KIND OF THING AND HE
SAID THE FBI WAS A WAS
STONEWALLING CONGRESS, THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES ON THIS.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF ROOM TO
TALK NOW THAT THEY ARE
COMPLAINING.
>> Laura: GIULIANI SAID WHEN
HE WAS ASKED BY HANNITY, OTHER
TWO SYSTEMS OF JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY, HE SAID ONE FOR
HILLARY, ONE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
HE IS THE LAWYER REPRESENTING
THE PRESIDENT BUT FOR A LOT OF
AMERICANS WHO ARE WATCHING
THIS -- YOU DESTROY DOCUMENTS,
YOU SMASH BLACKBERRIES, EVERYONE
GETS IMMUNITY.
YOU GET TO DO AN INTERVIEW, COZY
BEFORE THE FOURTH OF JULY.
NO TRANSCRIPT TAKEN, NEVER UNDER
OATH AND LOOK AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED ON THE OTHER SIDE TO
THIS PRESIDENT.
FOR A YEAR WITH ALL THIS
IMPORTANT STUFF HAPPENING IN THE
WORLD, HE HAS BEEN HOUNDED BY
HIS SPECIAL COUNSEL WHOSE OFFICE
IS POPULATED BY PARTISAN WOULD
NOT ONLY ARE JUST DEMOCRATS BUT
HAVE AN ANIMUS TOWARD THIS
PRESIDENT.
I HAVE TO SAY WHEN I HEARD RUDY
SAY THAT, I HAVE TO SAY I AGREE,
ALL THE EVIDENCE POINTS TO THAT.
>> I WOULD SAY THERE ARE THREE
SYSTEMS OF GOVERNMENT.
THERE'S ONE FOR HILLARY, THERE'S
ONE FOR NORMAL PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD AND THERE'S ONE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FROM DAY ONE, FROM KLAPPER
TELLING COMEY TO GO BRIEF THE
PRESIDENT ON THIS NONEXISTENT
RUSSIAN DRAMA, TO THE INCIDENT
THAT GIULIANI RECOUNTED, HE WAS
INTERVIEWED BY THE PRESIDENT FOR
THE JOB OF FBI DIRECTOR WITH
ROSENSTEIN SITTING NEXT TO HIM.
KNOWING THE PRESIDENT HAS
REJECTED HIM FROM THAT JOB.
THE DECK HAS BEEN STACKED WITH
AXES TO GRIND.
WHEN ROSENSTEIN'S ANGRY WORDS
CAME OUT AND MADE IT PERSONAL,
WHO DOES HE THINK HE IS?
HE WORKS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
I WAS SHOCKED AND JUST LIKE FBI
AGENTS ARE HANGING THEIR HEADS
IN SHAME, I'M SURE THERE'S A LOT
OF GOOD ATTORNEYS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WERE
STUNNED.
THAT PEOPLE ARE PICKING A FIGHT
WITH THEIR BOSSES LIKE THIS ON
TELEVISION.
>> Laura: I TWEETED THIS A
COUPLE OF MINUTES AGO BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE BIG MOMENTS IN
THIS INTERVIEW WAS WHEN GIULIANI
REFERENCE OF STORMY DANIELS
ISSUE.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
SOUND BITE, LET'S WATCH.
>> SOMETHING DO WITH PAYING SOME
STORMY DANIELS WOMAN 130,000,
WHICH IS GOING TO TURN OUT TO BE
PERFECTLY LEGAL.
THAT MONEY WAS NOT CAMPAIGN
MONEY, I'M GIVING YOU A FACT
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT CAMPAIGN MONEY.
NO CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
>> Sean: THEY FUNNELED THROUGH
A LAW FIRM.
AND THE PRESIDENT REPAID IT.
>> Laura: ON APRIL 6TH, THIS
WAS THE EXCHANGE.
>> DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
$130,000 PAYMENT TO STORMY
DANIELS?
THEN WHY DID --
>> YOU WILL HAVE TO ASK MICHAEL.
>> Laura: IT'S HARD TO HEAR
THERE BUT HE SAID NO, I DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT IT, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ASK MICHAEL COHEN ABOUT
THE PAYMENT.
PUTTING MY LEGAL HAT ON DURING
THE BREAK, -- DID HE PAY IT
AFTER APRIL 6TH?
THAT I'M OF THE LEFT IS JUMPING
ALL OVER THAT SAYING HE DIDN'T
KNOW, RUDY IS ON TV, WHAT'S
GOING ON?
>> THESE ARE REAL QUESTIONS, HE
GAVE US A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
VERSION OF THIS.
>> Laura: UNLESS THE PRESIDENT
PAID IT AFTER SIXTH.
HE KNOWS THAT'S WHERE IT'S
GOING.
>> IT APPEARS TO BE THE REAL
CONCERN IS THAT THERE WOULD BE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VULNERABILITY
ON THIS.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE THE
PRESIDENT ON TAPE ON
AIR FORCE ONE SAYING HE DID NOT